und dann hat die andere personal
geschrieben
beim ewigen jugend hey leute was gehabt
und jetzt willkommen waren ein video
habe ich hab natürlich stets gut also
eigentlich war heute ein anderes video
geplant nur irgendwie habe ich mir
gedacht er kommen das kann es auch mal
verschieben wir machen etwas anderes und
zwar habe ich gestern abend
es gibt ein video von mir da habe ich
irgendwie im moment dass man nicht
einmal kurz schauen genau da geht es um
die lustigsten whatsapp chats zwischen
pärchen und ich habe da glaube ich
gesagt bei 12.000 15.000 likes gibt es
noch ein paar davon aber noch etwas
ehrliches und ich habe gestern haben
gesehen dass wir dort fast 50.000 dax
nur irgendwie habe ich mich an die
abmachungen nicht gehalten also ich hab
keinen neuen part gebracht ja deswegen
habe ich etwas neues überlegt und zwar
geht es heute hat sie wahrscheinlich
habt ihr auch schon gelesen um die
lustigsten website chats wo halt jemand
schluss macht also so kapp mäßig
beziehung ist vorbei natürlich ist so
eine trennung nicht witzig das weiß ich
auch vor allem wenn man kann darüber
whatsapp schlussmann aber eigentlich ist
es halt schon in gewisser weise witzig
zumindest wenn man es dann so macht wie
in diesen fällen die ich jetzt
ausgesucht habt also vielleicht gar
nicht angelaufen
wir fangen an und ich wünsche euch viel
spaß das drumherum dabei haben wir sagen
einfach mal 15.000 likes weil er noch
mal bock habe auf so einem ort
verbringen dann gibt's das sofort
nächste woche ja und jetzt fangen ja und
zwar mit dem ersten schritt die eine
person hat geschrieben es ist 11 uhr 11
du kannst dir was wünschen dann schreibt
die andere person irgendwie 35 minuten
später ok und was wünscht du dir ich
wünsche mir dass unsere beziehung noch
fest serviert wird zusammenbleiben und
heiraten was wünscht du dir denn jetzt
und dann schreibt er oder sich einfach
einen weg zu finden um mit dem schluss
zu machen bevor es hier alles zu ernst
wird und dann kommt halt willst du mich
verarschen also in diesem fall war
glaube ich eine seite der beziehungen
total happy und die andere seite habe
überhaupt keinen bock mehr konnte aber
nicht übers herz bringen schluss zu
machen weil ich auf jeden fall so an
sich ganz lustig halter das nächste es
richtig heftig und zwar kann ich dir ein
paar fragen stellen fragt die eine
person die andere person antwortet okay
man hat jetzt fast auf die erste frage
er sie es wie ihr sie was fehlt zweite
frage du machst er sie es macht wir
machen ich punkt punkt punkt also ich
was muss da hin dritte frage das
gegenteil von anfang so und dann
beantwortet die andere
personen alle fragen erstens zweitens
drittens gegenteil von anfang jetzt
schluss alles zusammen untereinander
ich mache schluss perfekt gut ich hätte
das nämlich nicht übers herz gebracht
hey was war dein ernst also zumindest
creed ii also leuten die die schluss
machen wollen
irgendwie aber nicht wissen wie es ist
wenn eine gute variante also würde ich
mal sagen so weit kommen wir auch schon
zum nächsten chat verlauf und zwar
schreibt die eine person einfach ly
heißt so viel wie ein love you know
abkürzung funktion dann meinte die
andere person kannst du das bitte
ausschreiben das sieht dann sofort viel
süßes aus ja und wenn man mal nachdenken
natürlich heißt es abgekürzt love you
es könnte aber auch einem leaving you
heißen
und dann hat die andere personal
geschrieben einem liebling jugend ist
schon echt so wir machen weiter kommt
zur nächsten chat verlauf und zwar fängt
das dort an
wir müssen reden worüber müssen wir dann
reden ich denke wir brauchen eine pause
hektisch aber letzte nacht hatten wir
doch noch spaß ja und ich glaube dass
wir das in guter erinnerung halten
sollten schreibt halt so dann der junge
und dann antwortet das mädchen so von
wegen
ja genau ich werde einfach dieses bild
passten dann kann es jeder ein guter
erinnerung behalten und das bild kann
ich jetzt noch nicht zeigen weil ihr
könnt euch sicherlich vorstellen was das
im vorfeld natürlich ist das jetzt nicht
wirklich sonnenverlauf wo jemand schluss
macht aber ich fand es trotzdem ganz
witzig und habe das deswegen
reingenommen ich meine man muss ja
schließlich alles in sehr guter
erinnerung behalten und am besten postet
man es dann bei instagram so wie ich auf
meinem instagram account alexander posth
die wirklich sehr sehr schöne fotos
deswegen weniger nicht folgt ja einfach
mal kurz eingeblendet check deshalb
folgt mir leid meine fotos kommentiert
meine fotos oder schaut einfach weiter
dieses video das nächste fängt
eigentlich so an wie man das eigentlich
schon kennt also das kann ich zumindest
vorher schon und zwar hey willst du
einen zaubertrick hören jetzt weiß
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch was kommt
nur dem ganzen mut noch so eine krone
aufgesetzt sag ich mal und zwar hey
willst du ein zaubertrick hören andere
personen an bord klar schieß los du bist
ja toll langweilig andere personen
dachte sich das kannst du setzt dich mit
dem machen lassen was schreibst du sie
schreibt und willst du ein witz herrn
schieß los unsere beziehung
so das nächste ist auch geil und zwar
haley ich habe gesagt dass ich krank bin
noch nicht rausgehen kann
bist du bereich heute abend ja bin ich
kann gar nicht abwarten nicht meinem
bett zu haben
da hat jemand bock sie antwortete darauf
ich kann es auch nicht mehr abwarten
nächste woche mache ich schluss mit luke
versprochen so blöd gelaufen denn leo
antwortet kein stress kann ich auch für
dich machen übrigens hier ist luke und
nichtleben ofac habe ich nicht so
gemeint ehrlich da würde ich mal sagen
blöd gelaufen nur wer fremdgeht hat es
irgendwie auch nicht anders verdient
aber bekam all star game hierbei der
andrang noch so leute nächster zeit
verlauf hey ich muss dir was sagen okay
lass uns doch einfach gleichzeitig sagen
okay 123 erste person schreibt wollen
wir schluss waren zweite person schreibt
willst du mich heiraten alter das ist
richtig hart es ist glaube ich das
härteste von allen ist halt öfter so die
eine person macht sich total die
hoffnung hat richtig zukunftspläne die
andere person hat überhaupt keinen bock
mehr hängen so jetzt muss ich mal kurz
gucken ja also wirklich alles sehr sehr
trauriges verläufe
das traurige ist dass dieses video ist
eigentlich vorbei ist weil ich habe
wirklich etwas lustigste genommen und
mehr hab ich jetzt nicht gefunden aber
er könnte aber in die kommentare
schreiben
worüber der nächste bad gehen soll lasst
dann nach oben da war ich das video
gefallen hat wie gesagt bei 15.000 gibt
es das nächste whatsapp chats video und
wir sehen uns dann am sonntag wieder
sonst wird's nur einschalten des touch
oder instagram abchecken auf keinen fall
vergessen haut rein
auch jetzt klingelt wäre